[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] em
[Music]
Tucker word salad with a side of lies
and we were served yesterday
Tucker Carlson breaks his
unemployed silence
on Twitter
he says he'll see us later right that's
what he says he says I'll see you later
just like he said I'll see you on Monday
um here's my guess with Decker Carlson
and that he is now irrelevant I don't
know if you watched the um the video or
we're gonna watch it here it's not very
long
it doesn't say much other than other
than the projection that he's giving us
he talks about people in the media lying
which is um
Rich coming from Tucker Carlson
but yes yes Decker Carlson uh finally
broke his two-day silence three-day
silence whatever it is two-day silence
it was no 3D there you go three days
three days the guy stay quiet which is
like a new record for him I guess
um he talked about the media in the clip
how stupid they are which
you know sometimes
um we crossed past somewhere
but Tucker Carlson gives us a great view
of what may come or not from Decker
Carlson my guess is he's completely
irrelevant irrelevant just like Bill
O'Reilly is now
Bill O'Reilly appears on news Nation on
Chris Cuomo show that's where that's
where Bill O'Reilly resides
I mean I'm sure Bill O'Reilly has his
own little you know Niche
subscription service
where he has a little thing that he talk
he talks online and I'm sure that's what
Tucker Carlson's gonna do too he may do
something that's public Tucker that is
some surmised that maybe it's on Twitter
he'll have a show on Twitter
which honestly good luck Tucker because
the um the periscope
feature on Twitter [__] sucks so
until Elon fixes that good luck
broadcasting to Twitter it's horrible
broadcasting to Twitter is [__]
horrible
it's ridiculous
uh Periscope used to be better
and then Twitter bought Periscope and
then made it an actual internal tool as
opposed to an external tool so if he is
gonna broadcast to Twitter Something's
Gonna have to change which I mean I I
actually don't think that's a bad idea
right that may be one thing that
um oh Elon
can give Twitter that's great that's
better than what it is now
but more about the news because really
honestly this Tucker Carlson thing
why is everyone so [__] obsessed with
him now that he's fired again there's
we're gonna have a new obsession here
soon whoever's in that eight o'clock
spot
because that's truly what made Bill
O'Reilly popular that's with these right
Wingers that's what made Tucker Carlson
popular with these [__] right Wingers
is that spot that that's the that's the
prime time spot that has the most
eyeballs it always has been for Fox News
it's not that's not news
on Fox non-news
Eugene Carroll I guess takes the stand
again today
um did you did
I I didn't read her entire testimony on
the stand yesterday but apparently she
said that Donald Trump stuck his tiny
hand in her
in a dressing room that's what I heard
um I need to go verify this but
is that is that is that what is going on
in this trial
um he's denying it I guess of course
of course he is
why
why wouldn't he lie about something he's
lied about continuously of course he
would so apparently Donald Trump is uh
is lying
his ass off so we have that
also in the news
um all around the country in these state
legislators and I I've been saying this
I'm telling you for a long time that
listen
these Republicans in these state
legislators are trying to legislate
people out of existence and they're
trying to take away parental consent
um you see what's going on in Montana
as Representatives Zephyr up there is
fighting for her voice to be heard just
just her voice to be heard in Missouri
the governor is gonna he's thinking
about I just read this that he's gonna
call a special session
about transgender athletes in Missouri
they're going to have a special session
I think in the state of Missouri there's
there's less than five
uh transgender athletes
that are under the purview of of
Missouri state law
what the [__] you're gonna call a
special session
you're going to call a special session
this is this I'm telling you this is not
about transgender people I I know that
they're using the bigotry of their base
um to push their fascism in these State
houses but this is about parental
consent folks that's what this [__] is
about it's about individualism it's
about identity it's about Liberty it's
about you doing what the [__] and being
the [__] who you want
and they're taking it away and they're
taking away parental consent to give
parents the the ability
to let their children be who their
children want to be
I mean what's next are they going to
tell children they can't have a certain
haircut
you can't wear a certain type of clothes
it they're saying this stuff folks I'm
telling you and and I played you a video
yesterday these Christian nationalists
and they're not [__] hiding it
they're not [__] hiding it it ain't
like they're like oh no this has nothing
to do with our religion no they want God
they want their God in our government
and they want it in your [__] bedroom
they want it in your closet they want it
in your pants they want it in your
doctor's office they want it everywhere
God does not [__] belong
that's your choice listen if you don't
want to be transgender fine I'm okay
with that if you want to be religious
fine whatever that's cool if you if if a
woman listen to me if a woman wants to
make a health care decision that puts
her life at risk and that's the decision
she wants to make I fine I I can't
impede on their Liberty
if we if we start if we start governing
and taking away this person's Liberty
that group's Liberty the women's Liberty
of their health choices in their health
care they're gonna start coming after
yours this is how fascism Works how
don't we [__] understand this yet
we've had this in history I actually you
know what I talked to a historian
a second world war historian
a couple weeks ago and I think I might
bring him on the show because now is the
time to talk about this Now's the Time
to get someone who knows Nazi Germany
forwards backwards I I told you a while
back to watch a Netflix
uh documentary on Adolf Hitler it's
called Hitler a career which is kind of
weird but it it was made in 1977 and it
looks through a lens of Nazi Germany
which we cannot look through today it's
very interesting on the perspective in
the 1970s
of Nazi Germany but listen to me this is
how this [__] begins
this is how this [__] begins
and it's not it's not going to end which
transgender athletes or transgender
children it'll it'll just I mean Jesus
Christ they think drag queens listen
listen to me they think all drank Queens
are trans people
and they're not
they're not
and it's their Obsession it's their
complete utter obsession
with women who may or may not have a
penis that is their complete obsession
with this stuff none of none of them are
talking almost none of them are talking
about trans men they it's it's like
trans men don't even exist
they have they have no [__] clue no
clue
it's absolutely [__] bizarre
but if you look at it in a in a certain
light
maybe one of a perspective of 1930s
Germany then you would understand where
this is going and where they want to go
with this
uh in other news Kevin McCarthy
passes a bill with almost every single
Republican no no
Democrats voted on this budget budget
reduction where they are going to cut
veterans benefits by 22 percent
22 they want to cut veterans benefits
I'm not these [__] support the
veterans support the troops and that and
that oh you mean they're Liars oh
could have fooled me
uh Chuck Schumer
and the president I I guess the the
Administration has told them
you can take your veterans
um Healthcare and budget cuts and you
can stick them straight up your ass
because they're it's not gonna happen
you're gonna have to do something
about about this whole
debt ceiling thing so Kevin McCarthy he
succeeds in passing a bill but it's not
gonna go anywhere
um now normally in government how it
would work is the speaker of the house
would go to the majority leader in the
Senate and say here's what I passed what
are you going to pass
this is what we can get done and they
try to come somewhere in the middle but
I doubt that's going to happen here
um I I actually believe
that Kevin McCarthy
may not be able to raise the debt
ceiling until the very last moment
that's right I think Kevin McCarthy and
the Republicans
are going to ride up to the very second
that the deck ceiling
would would bust
are going to pass a bill just on the
debt ceiling and it's probably going to
be really quiet No One's Gonna know
they're not going to want anyone to
report on it
and their base is going to believe that
they pass this bill when the news is oh
the debt ceiling got increased
their base is going to believe and and
the and these Liars are going to be out
there selling that they passed this bill
as the increase to the debt ceiling
it's all [__] it's all fake just
like Marjorie Taylor Green's outrage and
these hearings is fake you can tell it's
[__] fake you can tell she doesn't
know what the hell she's talking about I
get a we get a clip
you're probably gonna show that today
so Kevin McCarthy finally passes a bill
and it's gonna go nowhere it's DOA Dead
on Arrival
and the reason why is because you cut
veterans benefits by among other things
by the way
this is a horrible a horrible [__]
bill
and for Americans but in particular
veterans which
you think you would think
you would think they would hide their
their hate for veterans
a little better than what they did but
nope
no no
hell no they're not gonna hide that
um someone says about Hakeem Jeffries
yes there is a Great Clip and I probably
will play the clip of the king Jeffries
um King Jeffries listen folks in 2024
that's one of the opportunities that we
have really good ones
um I I'm feeling very confident about
the presidential race at this point
um as as the left freaks out that
Biden's Biden's old like he was old last
time and they don't understand how
Democratic primaries work we went over
this the last two days with tyd
I mean they understand they're just
lying to their audience that's all
they're doing the same thing with the
mainstream media Main Street Media like
MSNBC or CNN those ageist [__]
they're not talking about how old Trump
is but you know anyways the point is
this the point is this I'm very
confident about the presidential race
but we have a great opportunity in the
House of Representatives and the great
opportunity is to make Hakeem Jeffries
probably the longest serving
speaker of the house I'm dead serious if
we can pull King Jeffries
Over The Line
right we can pull the house over the
line and give him a decent majority in
the house I believe a king Jeffries can
be one of the longest serving
speakers of the house
which would be absolutely [__] a
banger oh my God because the guy is 100
on message all the time he never quits
he's never off
I'm telling you and and if you want to
get [__] done in this country you have a
speaker of the house who's one of the
longest serving one of the most powerful
and and one that's on [__] message
every single time
he knows the narrative he knows the
message he knows the way of new
liberalism the new brand of liberalism
in this country
he's on point and and we're gonna need
someone the next two decades to get
fascism to hide back underneath this
rock up there in Washington DC making
sure that the institution of the House
of Representatives is taken care of and
the King Jeffries I think is the guy who
could do it and I'm telling you that's a
that's a huge that's a huge win if we
can get Hakeem Jeffries to be the
speaker of the house because I'm telling
you I really believe
he can be one of the longest serving
speakers in history I really do I think
he could I mean he's a young guy he
could serve as long as we keep him there
and he does a really good job
there would be no reason not to keep the
Democratic majority in the House of
Representatives we we know we
we know the Republicans in the house are
[__] worthless
in this country this country is already
um hip to the idea that Republicans are
not the ones to put in charge of
government we see what happens when we
do that they're [__] worthless they
can't get [__] done all they want to do
is cut veterans benefits when they get
the chance Jesus Christ do you think
those constituents who voted for
republicans
do you think if you ask each one of them
now they're too [__] dumb most of
them to understand this but if you ask
every single one of them you're like you
understand what they're you voted for
the people that are trying to cut
veterans benefits
they would like what what are you
serious yes dead dead ass serious
[__] you are voting for people
who are taking away veterans benefits
Ergo you're voting to take away veterans
benefits and we say this all the time
right we keep telling these dumb
[__] stop voting
if you love veterans if you want to
support veterans fine whatever stop
voting for [__] Republicans then
because you get all up in your [__]
weird feels about Miss Martian and
Women's Health Care
you [__] weirdos
oh you want veterans to have health care
in this country you want them to have
the benefits they earn to serving our
country well then stop voting for
Republicans stop it
stop
if you if you want freedom if you want
Liberty if you don't want politicians
telling you what the [__] you can and
can't do
who you can love what you can wear
they're gonna I'm telling you these
state legislators are going to legislate
what you can wear they're already doing
it Tennessee did it Texas did it
lizzo went to [__] Tennessee we I
missed I that was over the weekend
I watched the clip of lizzo she went she
went to did she go in that no it wasn't
Nashville
where what was it Nashville it might
have been Nashville I don't I don't
remember exactly where in Tennessee she
had the concert
but I was watching a clip of lizzo in
Tennessee
holding a concert right
and she's like bring out the drag queens
arrest me you [__]
I love it I [__] love it yeah and and
there needs to be more of that
and and she gave one of the best uh
speeches on stage
when she she said they told me not to
come to Tennessee and I said [__] that
[__]
I'm coming here and I'm speaking truth
and power and they can kiss my ass and
that's what we should do that's why you
remember when everyone wanted a boycott
Spotify because Joe Rogan's on Spotify
do you remember this and I said [__] you
I'm not I'm not getting my [__] up my
shit's not coming off Spotify that was
that was uh last year I believe last
year
when uh the clip of uh Joe Rogan came
out where he was saying the n-word Alex
Jones had um did this clip months and
months and months before when they were
interviewed Patriot takes posted on
Twitter everyone blamed it on Patriot
dicks they just pulled the [__] video
about that Alex Jones made of Joe Rogan
continually saying the n-word
with a hard R and and the world blew up
and ever all the Liberals and the left
wanted to boycott Spotify and I said no
I'm not and people there were some
people who were like I'm not watching
your show and I'm not listening to your
show if you're on Spotify and I said
good [__] you go I don't give a [__]
listen here's the thing the reason why
lizzo went to Tennessee is because
Tennessee needs her voice
okay that's that's what we need
we need to stand up against this [__] we
don't need to back down from them we
don't need a boycott [__] [__] that
nonsense [__] that nonsense that that
doesn't work anyways where's Spotify
today spotify's probably bought four or
five big ass companies since then and
become more powerful
and what happened to your boycott
where's your boy kind of Spotify now
it's stupid it's [__] dumb you know
what we need to spend our energy doing
winning [__] elections that's what we
need to do that's what our energy and
our [__] organizing needs to do [__]
boy conning [__] trying to
railroad one [__] it's dumb you
know what we need to do take back State
houses take back governorships take back
the House of Representatives can you
imagine if Akeem Jeffries was the
speaker of the house right now the debt
ceiling would done been raised folks
done been raised and they wouldn't be
trying to cut [__] veterans benefits
in the meantime
foreign
had at least at least not a super
majority of Republicans or Missouri or
Montana or whatever [__] dumb
backward state
House of Representatives there is
if they didn't have super majorities of
[__] Republicans yeah yeah we might
we might be able to talk about [__] that
matters to people not [__] taking
away parental consent because
Republicans are scared of two
transgender people in their state
yeah I don't think we need to spend our
[__] energy boycotting [__] or
canceling anybody [__] that [__] let's
keep our eye on the prize here folks
not for this [__] [__] let's mock
them with their culture Awards [__]
yeah someone says School Board races you
goddamn right put your [__] energy in
that and that's why I applaud lizzo not
only because she's a great artist she's
a damn good individual a damn good
person a beautiful person
and she's got a voice and a platform and
she knows how to use it she didn't not
go to Tennessee and boycott Tennessee
[__] said hey let's go to Tennessee and
show these [__]
let them [__] arrest me make a scene
[__] do it I dare you that's what we
need to do we need to stand in the face
of fascism
we do not need to we don't have to
tolerate intolerance [__] that [__]
go get em
beat that drum like I said I've got one
microphone only one
but you have thousands and lizzo is the
same way she's only got one microphone
but she's got millions of microphones
behind her
and we could do this [__] together
because this this 2024 race just isn't
about
the presidential election because really
honestly here's the thing here's the
thing
if you want to boil it down Joe Biden is
gonna [__] bin Donald Trump over his
knee and spank his little [__] stupid
ass that's what's gonna happen so what's
gonna happen folks I'm very confident
that's that's just this this [__]
country hates that [__] they
[__] we [__] hate Trump
we [__] hate him
I don't give a [__] I don't give a [__]
if you think Biden's old or he's not
good enough he's not liberal enough he's
not conservative enough he's not
moderate enough he didn't do this he
didn't do that he didn't give us this he
didn't give us this he promised this get
it get the [__] out of here with that
nonsense this country [__] hates
Donald Trump more than they hate anyone
on the face of this Earth
and that's just that's just pure and
simple and if you don't know that if you
don't know that the majority of people
in this country hate that [__]
you're a brainwashed delusional dumb
[__] just about as delusional and mind
[__] as Joe Biden can't beat him you
are a dumb [__] I'm sorry and if
you're here listen to this and you
and you don't like that I just keep
listening I don't know kick rocks I
don't give a [__] that's why when the
Spotify thing came I took lizzo's stand
the same way I'm not getting off Spotify
why the [__] would I do that then
there's no voice against Joe Rogan
there's no voice against the right wing
[__]
on Spotify [__] that you saw left-wing
people leaving leaving leaving Spotify
I'm like there's not gonna be any left
wing left there's no going to be no
liberal message left on Spotify it's
only gonna be right Wingers then what
are you gonna do you [__] idiots just
like lizzo said hey look I'm not boycott
in Tennessee
Tennessee needs the voice Tennessee
needs to hear it
they need to deal with it that's it
that's it
so get with it turn up your [__]
microphone make it into a megaphone
because we're getting started
right here right now just like we do
every single weekday Monday through
Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific
on YouTube Twitter and twitch
and simulcasting to Facebook
the books of face so don't forget to
subscribe to the YouTube channel you're
not going to want to miss an episode
every single weekday all two hours also
follow us on Twitter at Tony Michaels
pod
you're not going to want to miss it over
there in case um in case Elon changes
the Periscope application for Tucker and
it makes it easier to broadcast over
there fine great I'm I'm all for that so
go ahead and follow us on Twitter before
Twitter Burns To The Ground also if
you're on Facebook or still have a
Facebook account make sure to follow us
there at the Tony Michaels we broadcast
there too on the books of face just
follow us over there
also I want to thank everyone out there
who has renewed their subscription on
Twitch with their Amazon Prime account
that's right if you
have an Amazon Prime account you get one
free subscription on Twitch and if you
link your Amazon Prime account to your
Twitch account
we get a few dollars of Amazon's money
it's like two or three bucks something
like that it's like five dollars and
then by the time they take this fee and
that fee and then they charge you this
fee it's like two or three bucks but it
adds up when a lot of you do it when I
right now we had almost 100 doing it but
it's gone down and the reason why is
because you have to go renew it each
month so you got to go and I know it's a
pain in the ass and I think
someone out there has a video of how to
do it I just I gotta figure out a way to
put it out there somewhere so you guys
can find it so that way you can figure
out how it takes like three seconds
three seconds to renew it your once you
link the two and uh it doesn't take very
long at all and I do want to thank
everyone who went over to Twitch and
subscribed not just subscribed but
followed on Twitch because we have
almost 900 followers on Twitch we're
trying to get to a thousand so everyone
who's went over there you know I have to
I mean you can subscribe but you can
follow for free it doesn't cost anything
to follow
um and it doesn't cost anything if you
have an Amazon Prime account they'll
link them together so thank you for all
the support on to which
also a special announcement I know I
said I'd have a new merch today that may
or may not have to do with a rake link
um let them eat rake we are working on
that we have a preliminary design so
hopefully sometime today you know what I
might do
once we get a better
preliminary design this one's kind of a
real rough draft but once we get a
preliminary design I might go post it on
patreon to see what you guys think where
you guys can give some critiques over
there so you guys have some say in this
merch design so go to patreon.com
the Tony Michaels that's patreon.com the
Tony Michaels or you can go to the Tony
michaels.com click the patreon link at
the very top
it'll take you to the patreon page and
you will be able to become a member and
you'll see and maybe maybe I'll do like
a voting thing or something I don't know
I'll put a design once we get a better
workable design today sometime I'll put
it up over there I'm hoping by tomorrow
um we'll be able to have it in the merch
store so we'll see we've got you know
that the person who did our dank Brandon
and dark Brandon design here is the um
here's the let's see
here's the dark Brandon here's the dark
brand and design it's the same same
artist
who did this uh designed and you go to
store.dtonymichaels.com that's
store.thetonymichaels.com that's another
way you can find support first but
that's where the design will be once we
decided but to go to patreon.com the
Tony Michaels or D Tony michaels.com
click the patreon link and I'm hoping
today maybe tomorrow morning we'll put
something over there as preliminary
design you guys can give some input and
help us come up with this design I
always like when you guys kind of pick
things up
yeah yeah so um there may or may not be
some rake merch on its way okay
[Laughter]
oh boy we got a lot of Clips to get to
including this Tucker Carlson clip so
stick around don't go anywhere we'll be
right back right after this
what the [__] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow Patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny we
know what you would do you'd reach out
and give that true American a hand now
here's your chance for only fifty
dollars a day you can help us help those
true Americans recover from Biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those Trump supporters and this is that
moment send your donation via venmo to
the real president Donald J Trump it's
only fifty dollars a day recurring and
it means you'll get these Trump
supporters the critical help they so
desperately need to survive under this
false regime please donate now because
those Trump supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment [__]
um we're
back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show Boy again
[Music]
I said go follow on Twitch and we got
the 890 am yeah 899 for damn near 900 we
just need one more follower over there
on Twitch they get 900. so you guys uh
you're the best audience in the world
you really are and it's the best chat in
the world here on YouTube
but it's probably the best chat in the
world on Twitch too I mean to be quite
honest
I'm not you know just saying that that's
probably what it is over there so if you
like if you like the chat on YouTube go
follow on Twitch and then maybe just
maybe maybe you'll find a great chant
family over there on Twitch because we
have a great twitch family chat family
over there too the [__] Em's fam is
large
and getting bigger
and we have a great chat family on
Facebook too don't forget yeah see Kelly
says don't forget Facebook
I don't forget Facebook you know I I
don't I
to be honest with you Kelly I [__]
hate Facebook I'm not much on Instagram
either but here's the thing
here's the thing
is you almost gotta be on these
platforms where you're broadcasting if
you want this thing to reach as many
people as you can because some people
prefer to watch it on their Facebook
some people want to watch it on Twitch
some people want to watch it on YouTube
and that's the one reason why I have it
on Twitter more than anything it's
horrible like the broadcast is horrible
that's why no one hardly watches it
there because it's hard to watch on
Twitter
but maybe if Tucker does do a deal with
Yvonne maybe just maybe
the broadcasting capabilities will get a
little better
over on Twitter because they [__]
suck right now that's why but they so so
a lot of people a lot of trolls will be
like oh you only got 10 people oh 12
people watching oh you're a dumbass no
one likes your show like you [__]
idiot that's the broadcast on Twitter No
One watches the broadcast on Twitter
anyways that's why I put my website and
that's why I the link to my website and
I put the link to the YouTube to direct
people there
and we get hundreds of clicks on the
YouTube link that's how some people find
the [__] show link is they they're on
their Twitter account it pops up and
they click the [__] link because I
put it in there sometimes I forget to
put the link on the broadcast and people
are mad they're like Hey where's the
[__] show like I I go to the YouTube
channel you can find it there but they
just use I just use that to so they can
click the link Twitter [__] sucks
when you're broadcasting
sex it's horrible it's horrible
see see and see Carolyn knows I'm off
twit never liked it exactly I I like
Twitter some people don't
some people like twitch some people like
YouTube
you know it's just a preference and we
just I just want to try to reach as many
uh of the audience as I can in as many
places I can and I want to broadcast it
for free two hours every day for you to
watch so it doesn't cost you a thing to
come here and watch this show two hours
a day but I appreciate all your support
all the people on patreon that's how I
make a living is patreon with the extra
content I actually just posted
a a new clip that will be coming out
sometime later today on all the socials
you'll get to see it but patreon gets
the first view of it so it's over there
so and that's how that's how I you know
makes a living because I'm doing this uh
full time now that's what two hours a
day is five days a week and then I do
the extras uh for um patreon and I think
probably tomorrow right after the show
we'll do ask me anything so right after
we do the show I'll be editing and I'll
do ask me anything while I'm editing
it's all like you I'll be doing two
things
at once we're gonna have Gabe Sanchez
here today I promise I promise
um add in the neck to what is this
question
Tony can you add add in the neck
to the [__] logo
[__] him in the neck is that what you're
saying [__] them in the neck
I boss man of Texas hey
I don't know
I I guess but I don't I don't know why
in the neck
not really sure but you know maybe it's
a thing maybe you know some people have
a foot fetish some people have a neck
fetish I guess I don't know I don't know
oh looky there people are going over to
Twitch and following we just went over
900 so we're at 902
um someone on someone on YouTube's
pointing it out that we have 902 on
Twitch are you watching on both
I know some people like
the watch on both
um yes we are over 900 there on Twitch
and I'm I'm behind apparently
904. see look at this God damn no let's
keep going let's see if we can get a
thousand today how many of you think
that we can get a thousand over on
Twitch today
because I was thinking
uh you guys follow everywhere and we did
hide and seek on Gabe's channel was that
the week before last I think something
like that we played hide and seek where
we went on Gabe's Channel and everyone
came over there and watched it on Gabe's
Channel
um and and I just to get him some
followers and some support over on his
channel I was thinking maybe we'll do
hide and seek on my Twitch account just
to get people over there to to to follow
over there because it didn't cost
anything to follow over there I don't
know
um
so
but it it is um there's a lot of people
there's new people in the chat over
there on uh twitch
everybody's um
up there's
um Don fizzle just subscribed with prime
over on Twitch thank you very much has
someone else just renewed their
subscription re-subscribed on Twitch
twitch is lighting up over there you you
are God damn
you people I are the best in the world
you really are I I'm I'm dead serious it
it makes me so excited
that um there's people out there that
want this message to continue that want
this show to continue and what they want
it to keep going and you guys are
showing support it means a lot it really
does mean a lot to to me and and I know
it means a lot to uh Gabe Sanchez he's
not here yet but he will be here today
he is gonna be on the show I know
yesterday I said he
'd he'd be here and he he wasn't
no no I yesterday wasn't here I think I
said he wasn't
I think it was um Tuesday when Texas
Paul was on he was he was kind of late
he had a meeting or something that he
had to go to or something something
um
some people are are over there on Twitch
there we go 911 we're at 911. should I
just keep counting here
you guys are awesome uh thanks for going
to Twitch and giving us some support
over there it really helps out there's
another another person subscribed uh
with their Prime account
so we have that's three people today I
think four people maybe I think that's
four and then we had a few new
re-subscribes
over on Twitch so I appreciate it a lot
all the support that we get over on
Twitch
don't forget about Facebook and YouTube
either but today's twitch day apparently
everybody's um on the train over there
and giving us followers and support and
and Amazon Prime subscriptions over on
Twitch and again while we're talking
about it if you go and you link your
Amazon Prime account to your Twitch
account you get one free subscription so
it doesn't cost you a thing it doesn't
cost you a thing if you have an Amazon
Prime account to subscribe not just
follow but subscribe
to the Johnny Michaels podcast over on
Twitch and what happens is is we get a
few dollars of Amazon's money that's
what happens Amazon sends us a few bucks
for you using your Amazon Prime account
to subscribe to our Channel over on
Twitch so if you want to do that and
show support it gives us monetary
support without spending an another
nickel of your money
if you're an Amazon Prime account holder
so in other words if you already have
Amazon Prime it doesn't cost you any
extra because you get one free one but
you have to renew it every single month
so if you've done that before
you have to go back in and and
resubscribe just go to Twitch and just
hit re-subscribe it takes like three
seconds so and there's more people
following
um what are we up to now what are we up
to let's see let's
refresh 913 look at that we're gonna get
to a thousand today
I really think we're gonna get to a
thousand
you people are like oh
you want a thousand you want a thousand
followers on Twitch you say Tony well
that's what we're gonna do [__]
and you guys just do it so it's great
you guys are the greatest audience in
the world Gabe Sanchez is going to be
joining us uh we better get down to some
business here I'll keep an eye on the uh
the twitch
I'll keep an eye on it over there and
um we'll we'll we'll keep updating on
the entire audience about how twitch is
going
um here someone says um how uh Tony how
much money do you get from twitch if we
subscribe for five bucks see that's
that's the thing is they take fees from
it so like even when you um like when
you do the Prime account it's like a
it's a free five dollars right so it's
like five dollars a month is what we get
but we don't get the whole five bucks
it's like three dollars or some [__] I'm
not sure exactly how much it is I don't
even know how they calculate it but they
have all the fees that are built in like
they I think they charge you something
they charge me something so it's kind of
weird so if you really want to give five
dollars if that's what you want to do
because because I'm not opposed to you
going to the tip jar you can go to the
tonymichaels.com and drop five bucks in
the tip jar I'll get more of it if that
makes sense but like if you have an
Amazon Prime account and you subscribe
for free then it's free money for you
and and and free money support for us it
doesn't cost anything that's why I kind
of like that if you have a Prime account
so I I don't say go subscribe and spend
five bucks I mean you can do that if you
want to there's several people that
subscribe on Twitch that spend their
money which that's fine what however you
want to do it it's again I'm All About
Liberty and freedom if you if you wanna
if you wanna support the show and you
don't have five bucks to give that's why
I have it for free so you can come and
you can chat you can share it around you
can like it uh you can comment you can
share with your family and friends that
doesn't cost much you can share it
around on social media because it's free
that's why it's free I want the show to
be free if you want to have extra
content you go over patreon and you can
have extra content over there depending
on what tier you're in
if you want to show us monetary support
on Twitch you can subscribe or you can
use your Amazon Prime account it doesn't
cost you anything to give us a couple
bucks
um with your Amazon Prime account which
is kind of cool and I I thank you
forever any support
um if you want to go to the tip jar a
lot of people go to the tip jar just go
to the Tony michaels.com the tip jars at
the top and if you I get the most amount
of the money when you do it that way so
if that's what you're looking for if
you're just looking to every once in a
while show some monetary support when
you can when it's convenient for you
that's the easiest way uh quickly
without having all the fees and stuff
speaking speaking of expense
I I don't know it's a transition I'm
trying to go with eight cinches we're
getting a lot of Support over on Twitch
this morning uh let's see what it's up
to we were below 900 just below 900 uh a
little bit ago and I said something
about that and the audience is like oh
hold my beer and now we're at 9 20. oh
damn dog I think we're gonna get to a
thousand today I really think so and I
think there's uh there's like almost 10
new subscribers with prime already thank
you very much we have the best audience
I'm telling you they're great fantastic
they're great fantastic
all right so I gotta ask you because you
were I so last night I was at karaoke
I'm at the bar oh that's right that
would explain why you weren't on the
face yeah so Mario you already know
where I'm going with this so Mario Mario
was trying to get me to come into space
and I couldn't hear it because it's
[__] loud in the bar yeah
I might or might not have been
um under the influence of Jagermeister
actually
to be quite honest I think I had I think
I think I had a margarita in advance
okay I mean you started the you started
the night off right you didn't end well
tequila Margaritas you like what's your
favorite Margaret uh uh if you can make
a classic totally about that if you can
make like
you know it's defensive if you like if
you want like a Reposado tequila you
want like all right with all the details
see this guy's a detail guy I'm like hey
hey you got a frozen strawberry
margarita
I'm like yeah give them Frozen yeah and
that's how I say it dude I'm like give
me one of them you know the last
strawberry the last time I had a
strawberry margarita a frozen strawberry
margarita was at a spot here in LA and
uh
no no it tasted it tasted like soup like
it
um how's the best way to describe this I
like it because it's a tequila slushie
basically yeah no that's it if you can
make if you can make a frozen margarita
I'm all about that I mean okay oh here
now wait now wait wait wait wait wait go
ahead go ahead I was gonna say the key
to uh some of the best frozen margaritas
that I've had is even just a basic right
we go lime right
uh tahin on the rim
right so so this past weekend I actually
had a Paloma
um
and okay people saying the audio is
crackling
I don't know I said no is it his audio
or is it mine Tony your mic is crackling
oh
now how is that
I don't know testing testing my oh here
we're gonna
is it fine with me
both are bad okay go out and come back
in then
go and come back in we're having audio
difficulty
Gabe isn't fine
oh
is it still is mine still bad with him
out
how's mine with him out hmm
yep test test both are [__]
okay when he comes back in
um and when he comes back
I'll go out and then come back in
someone's saying great it stopped when
Gabe left
I think I think people are saying people
are saying it it stopped when Gabe left
how about now how about good are we good
with Gabe now everything good with Gabe
I mean look I can always leave you know
I can just go [__] myself is The
Universe telling you Jake get the [__]
out of here you're fine Tony nope poor
Gabe Gabe started it back
is it me is it really me it's back yeah
it's back and guys I'll just see you
tomorrow I'll see you later if it's
crackling I can always leave I don't
want the odd to be bad for the [__]
audio side can you uh can you uh
go back restart your computer and then
or something yeah all right it might be
yeah it might be that way you're using
the wave right yeah yeah
we'll see you later
okay we're gonna go with just me for
right now and see if we can get Gabe's
audio back I do want to give you an
update on Twitch the twitch we're gonna
get to a thousand today it's at 9 27.
it's at 9 27 Gary what's up let's see
Stacy
um Stone uh let's see one two three you
got you guys are fantastic we've got 75
uh new subscribers and there's like I
don't know it's almost 20 I think I
don't remember how we started with
um it's like 20 new Prime subscribers
over on
twitch and we're almost we're getting to
a thousand fast uh 927 so everything's
happening wildly over on Twitch so I
appreciate it as we work through some
audio problems with Gabe's inches I bet
it's his software
um these mics that we use this one here
this is a it's called an Elgato wave
three
and it runs off of software so my guess
is my guess is is that his software
needs an update or something like that
so that's why he needs to he needs to
restart his computer he needs to restart
his computer and then um and then it'll
be fine so okay let's do some serving of
the interwebs
and the Tweety tweets and trendy trends
we're gonna go to the shitless Roundup I
like the music we're back to the music
now I did the music yesterday we'll do
it today let's start the countdown
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
the [__] list
welcome back to the shitless Roundup
[__] list Roundup okay let's start with
let's see
hell boy got a lot of video to show you
I want to wait till uh Sanchez comes
back for the Tucker Carlson but I do
want to show you this video about
Florida Rhonda Santos is apparently
um
sending shots to Trump in Israel this
guy he thinks he's gonna run he moved up
okay
I told you that Rhonda Santos is not
going to get in this race and his window
is closing right and I said that I don't
know that he's going to
and I don't know it's about six weeks
ago four or six weeks something I don't
know I lose track
Ron DeSantis team said he thinks he's
going to announce in June
okay you got it and I said [__]
yesterday people are are guessing that
Rhonda Santos is going to move his
announcement to May because his windows
closing someone's listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast down there in Florida
hey Ronnie Ronnie resign as Governor
dude I'm telling you
and if if you're gonna listen to me
[__] listen to me what I'm telling
you to do
if you want to have any chance at all to
beat Trump here's what you do meatball
resign as Governor today because you're
not going to get that exception fast
enough
and an ounce that's what you need to do
if you want to be on the stage
if you don't if you wait [__] two
three more weeks four more weeks you're
gonna be more and more irrelevant man
it's not gonna go well for you you're
gonna get [__] trounce you're already
getting drounced because you're a weirdo
you're come on [__] you're a weirdo man
so resign now and announce don't wait
till May but you notice how they moved
it up
is that window's closing Tony's right
always
um Dwayne Wade
is a former member of the Miami Heat I
don't does he play for the Miami Heat
right now I don't know I don't watch
sports I ain't gonna have time for
[__] Sports I got enough [__]
politics to keep up on I can't do Sports
too Jesus [__] Christ there's too
much [__] but Dwyane Wade did an
interview
um and in this interview he was asked
about living in Florida and not living
in Florida uh here here is the result of
his answer he's like no I'm not living
in Florida because it's a [__] here
we go what do you have to say to some of
those state legislators who maybe have
your jersey in their closets who came
and brought their kids to your game to
cheer for you
um well you know I think that's that's
another reason why I don't live in a
state a lot of people don't know that I
have to make decisions for my family
um not just personal individual
decisions I mean obviously the taxes is
great you know having way county is
great but my family would not be
accepted or feel comfortable there what
what
was really big news or is it just like
yeah that makes sense Dwayne Wayne has
enough money to pay taxes someplace else
and it's worth that amount of money to
him for his family not to be in [__]
danger because it's a fascist state
and and he wants his family to be
accepted
hmm feel feels like it feels like the
fashion thing in Florida isn't going to
turn out well
over time this [__] this trend of
fascism in Florida is not gonna work out
in the long run for them it's just not
it's not that shit's not shit's not cool
man when you're doing that kind of [__]
it just isn't
um I believe Rachel Nichols was the one
who did that uh interview I think that's
who that is I don't know I I don't know
who she is but
I think it was on an account Rachel
Nichols so I think that's who it is
anyways
you want to know this is in Texas Texas
is the same [__] way folks Texas is
trying out Florida Florida it's just a
thing
it's just a thing uh someone says he's
talking uh on Twitch they said he's
talking about his trans daughter I I
Dwyane Wade might have a trans daughter
I I don't know that for sure but I mean
anyone's family I'm telling you if
you're a parent and you have children
your consent is at stake the state wants
to Ward your [__] children they want
to tell them who they're going to be
and they want to take your consent away
from you
that's what they're trying to do so I
don't care if it's trans daughter
daughter son trans son I don't care
these states are moving towards taking
away parental consent and they're using
it under that guise of the hating trans
people
but they're taking away your [__]
Liberty I don't care who your kids are I
don't care what they identify as that
has nothing to do I mean they're using
that as their tool to take away your
Liberty
but they're taking away your liberty no
matter
who your children are it doesn't matter
because if they take away the the
consent
of the people appearance of trans
children they're taking away your
consent too so don't [__] think that
oh well my kids not trans so it's not a
big deal you [__] [__] it ain't
[__] it ain't
you hide and watch you want me to give
you proof here you go here's proof in
Texas listen to this [__] this
[__]
this [__] is on the school board
or wants to be on the school board or
some [__] listen to this [__]
thank you
when I got elected last year uh Emerald
Globe News came and interviewed me hello
you notice a trend with these
[__]
and I'm just going to point it out
and a trend is they're they're all white
men right it's white men hmm
seems like there's something going on
there but listen to this [__] this
white Christian nationalism here it goes
this is School Board this guy was
elected he just said it to the school
board listen after school board meeting
over this subject and uh you know it's
not going to happen on my watch and
that's kind of where I'm at the schools
need to stay in their Lane Reading
Writing resident history
guy can't guy wasn't even educated well
enough
to understand that listen school's about
learning it's about education but it's
also about I don't know people
people their children are human beings I
don't even know this oh man you get you
guys give a [__] about fetuses oh my God
you're obsessed with fetuses
but but children
one's walking around
are human beings that and they grow up
to be adult human beings it's amazing
it's almost like uh facts and Truth
you [__] pieces of [__] education no
matter how you square it
might take and riding as if they're as
if they're [__] numbers
as if it's a prison or something these
are cattle
these are [__] human beings not only
are the students human beings the
teachers are [__] human beings
they're people too you [__]
how don't you know
that
education in schools public schools in
particular
are a people
business
a people
Fang
it's the same [__] when they talk
about school lunch
and children affording school lunch or
who can and who can't afford it [__]
that [__] give all children I don't care
who they are how much their parents
[__] make I don't care I don't give a
[__] feed them
you got the cafeteria you got the food
you got the funding you should add the
funding you better get the funding and
[__] feed those goddamn children
they're human beings they're people
okay they're they're walking around
they're live
they're not fetuses they're not clumps
of cells they're real human beings
[__] with human problems
and human causes and they needed to be
treated like [__] humans not cattle
you [__] but listen to how he
wants to treat him great job class too
Steve anyway uh you know
the whole agenda of the gay transgender
LBGTQ plus whatever it is alphabet
Community as I've referred to them and
some people may not think that's correct
but that's the way I did and then inside
is a teacher at Randall OH school board
meeting and call me a bigot that's
because you are you [__] bigot oh
when you're like yeah yeah the alphabet
knows alphabet demons because he says it
he [__] says it listen to this [__]
listen
and the man that I resigned I mean I am
not a bigot I'm not a racist yeah you
are yes I just don't think the school
board has any business and sex education
you are promoting he had no business in
education no business in education
especially that sex education that makes
me feel uncomfortable it makes me feel
uncomfortable when you have to be
educated about six
what the [__] are you talking about you
[__] boneheads man these these
[__]
this is what I said in the first 30
[__] minutes
I've been saying it over and over and
over again
stop wasting your time with [__]
boycotts and stupid [__] you need to
be down you need to have all this energy
focused in on your state legislators and
your [__] school boards because
listen to what else this piece of scum
says promoting a perverse
uh degenerate demonic thing that's from
the devil because there is nothing right
people you know it's a it's a mental
issue it's not uh it's not anything that
we need to be dealing with in school now
Gabe Sanchez this is why we need to have
education in school
this guy thinks that lgbtq is is demonic
of course it's the demons
who is that person he's on the school
board in a Texas school board oh God and
he's like someone called me a bigot
that's because you are man yeah I mean
look you sound yeah when thinking of
sound when you just watch like a bit
Yeah well you can do oh that was just so
you a swastika uh yeah how do I sound we
good or do I have to leave forever do a
test do a test heyo everybody it's
Thursday yeah we got bonehead of the
week coming later
don't see you're good I think it was I
think it was your software I think it
was your wavelength software oh awesome
awesome that's what it was that's what
it was that wait did you download the
new update on your wave no that's what
it is man there's a new update I I put
it off for days and I finally did it and
I had to restart my computer a couple
times so I need to I haven't updated so
you mean I'm I have wow you're fine now
stay stay where you are don't [__] with
anything right and then later when we
get off the air right right okay okay
You're Gonna Wanna down somebody
somebody asked this bonehead later today
what I mean by that is the voting the
voting the voting today we'll put the
poll out yeah yeah the poll is coming up
right it still works on Twitter because
elon's out [__] he's a liar yeah he's
a liar dude anyway do you think I don't
know if you guys talked about this in
that Twitter space because we we kind of
breezed over that because of the sound
issue yeah yeah we'll come back you want
to do it we can talk about it do you
think that
Tucker is gonna make a deal with Twitter
and you're gonna try to broadcast to
Twitter no no no no honest honestly I
would be excited about that because it
would Crash and Burn because it's
Twitter but maybe they would get the the
broadcasting platform to work better
over there Periscope is [__] right away
so here's here's what I think I think
it's a possibility and it's something
that uh everyone in this the spaces you
had fucking.com saying that he knew what
was going on with the contract it was
funny because it was people on the right
yet you had kim.com this other guy
Michael who's like oh I know Tucker uh
he's like you can't
uh he's like everything that we say here
is speculation like I haven't seen a
contract kim.com you haven't seen a
contract Kim's like oh I know Sean
Hannity and Michael this guy Michael's
like look as a journalist unless you've
spoken to Hannity in the last like month
or so in your private information about
the relationship between the Murdoch's
and Tucker Carlson then what you're
doing is also speculation
and um
they kind of went around and around so
what what was kim.com claiming that it's
going to be Kim no no no so this well uh
kim.com which he's an idiot by the way
yeah just show the audience knows Nazis
memorabilia Harlan Taylor fascist
um okay and international criminal but
yeah whatever
um so
he's also very sensitive he has me
blocked because I I said that he was
most of them in the space block me now
yeah yeah they don't like it so they get
all triggered when I say something but
they block me right I don't block them I
don't have anything yeah the only people
I block is when I'm put on these dumb
lists on Twitter right and it's like oh
look at this Democratic pedo and I'm
like look I don't want to be in this
list you know you know you can you know
you can stop walking it takes you off
the list I think
oh really yeah so you block and then
unblock right away and it takes you off
the list because because it says oh
you're blocked and then it takes you out
the list
I just the way I look at them like I
don't want so many of them though I
gotta go yeah it takes me like an hour
to get all these stupid [__] the way
that I look at it is like if I just
block you completely then I never have
to worry about being on the list again
and then I don't have to go someone's
saying crackle crackle oh no oh sound is
cracking again hey guys it was fun I'll
just see you tomorrow uh maybe I do need
to update my software let me do that and
then I'll come back I think that's what
it is I think that's what it is [__] all
right well what
how is it now how is it now is it I
think it's it's software I think it's
his software needs that update I believe
that's what it is I think that's what it
is you know um while I'm doing that I'm
gonna um I'm gonna move to a different
video I really want to talk about this
Tucker thing if he ever comes back
um but here's the thing is uh on Twitch
you guys are phenomenal you guys are
phenomenal
939 on Twitch which is great we're gonna
get to a thousand today I just I have a
feeling I have a feeling oh someone says
a spare mic I should tell him that I
think he's got one
um spare Mike
uh um
he needs to hook up hook up different
mic
you guys are geniuses we're supposed to
be the broadcast Geniuses over here and
you're giving us ideas look
uh I'm hungover still to be quite honest
um I know it doesn't seem like it is it
maybe it's just every day uh I'm
hungover and it's just a thing
um Kathy says thousand twitch day we're
gonna get there 940 now 940 and we have
we have like 20 more uh Prime
subscribers so there's been one two uh
three four five six just in the last 15
minutes
um yeah so just in like the last 15
minutes we've had six of them so thank
you for all the support on Twitch today
that's freaking awesome I can't wait to
get to a thousand subscribers over there
on Twitch and you guys make it happen
every single time uh when we need
support it's you guys are the best the
best and and when you're um telling us
how to run our microphones that's great
too so
Mike says Tucker sucks now he's
irrelevant
yeah as George Carlin the famous George
Carlin says the late great George Carlin
says [__] Tucker Tucker sucks
um so I think I think that's really
honestly where it's going is
Tucker is irrelevant and when we get six
months or eight months from now he'll
have something that he's talking to but
he ain't gonna have the millions of
people and P even people on the right
I'm like oh Tucker's all washed up [__]
Kim you know they'll turn on Tucker too
they'll turn on Tucker they'll they'll
do it
um
uh someone says let's see the Tucker
interview Carolyn on Facebook we're
gonna watch the tucker video I promise
and I'm gonna bash the [__] out of it
but let's go to a different video on why
we're waiting and you probably
let's see here which one do I want to
show uh I showed the school board one I
showed Dwyane Wade
um
oh someone updated the uh the meme a
great meme here's an update of the meme
I want to show you this Nate over on um
over on Twitter uh updated the meme he
changed my face to a laughing face
um so you know Zach goes
I I told him I said he said he likes
this one better because he put a little
more time into it
um but I said I I think it makes me look
a little chubbier which I'm not against
I'm not against I think that's not a bad
thing because Maga will make fun of it
and they'll hate it more so I'm all for
that anything that pisses them off
anything gets them all up in their
fields
I'm good with oh
um here is that
um clip of Madge Madhuri Taylor green uh
speaking of people trying to take your
parental rights away they even they
oh man they're like oh put your baby
zipper adoption put your babies up for
adoption you know don't don't abort
don't abort those fetuses put them up
for adoption and then Margie Taylor
Green's like oh you're a non-biological
parent that means that means you're not
a parent what the [__] it pick a lane
pick a would you pick a [__] belief
and stick to it already Jesus [__]
Christ people are all over the [__]
map God damn it's like Gabe Sanchez's
audio
I mean honestly are we better are we
better now well did you switch your mic
I did switch my mic okay does it sound
like I switched my mic yes it sounds
like you switched your mic it's not the
mic is not as good as the wave whatever
mic you're using but I'm on the yeti
right now yeah but it's it's down here
because I can't get it down down where
it's down if I just talk down to my mic
right now so you gotta you gotta talk to
your what I can bring it up here if you
guys want to hear me talk real nicely
you sure now it's echoey they say I I
don't I don't think that that mic is on
I think you got your other mic on okay
because when you brought it up to your
mouth it didn't get louder I'm just
saying you with your mic I'm telling you
man I don't know yes that's boom it was
it was I before I came in before I came
in it was
someone says wait Yeti Petty Yeti no no
there is a microphone called a Yeti
anyways I'm talking
okay you enough with the ASMR you're
gonna get these people all horny in the
chat doing that and then and then
there's gonna be all kinds of mayhem
welcome back to a tricky Thursday where
I tell you all about what I did the
night before
I had pizza with some friends oh my God
I made s'mores growing up it was good
this is I'm telling you the chant is
gonna go crazy these people are gonna be
switching over to Pornhub here soon and
uh we went so
much
[Laughter]
we should have like a [__] border
like Harold like a safety board you know
how many days it's been zero days
[Laughter]
uh yeah so uh here's a clip of the petty
Eddie
um and uh this clip is as bad as she had
a few moments uh from yesterday I I saw
uh well this is this is the one that is
dumber than dog [__] but it is Marjorie
Taylor green so what do we expect let's
listen are you a mother
I am a mother by marriage by marriage I
see
um and my wife is here with me so I'm
really glad that she's here right here
this Wine Garden I reclaim my time I
didn't ask you a question what I'd like
to talk about is your recommendations to
the CDC as not a medical doctor not a
biological mother
um and and really not a teacher either
you had no business advising the CDC
what the medical guidelines were for
school closures because now we have a
nation of school children who have
suffered because of it the problem is is
people like you need to admit that
you're just a political activist not a
teacher not a mother and not a medical
doctor Mr chairman I I just want to mix
note that um the the decorum of the
attacks on the witness were unacceptable
that the gentlelady from Georgia just
did and so it'd be nice if we didn't
attack the witnesses
um particularly whether or not making a
decision about whether not she's a
mother you are a mother thank you for
for being a great parent thank you
oh look empathy oh man yeah yeah again
again it's it's always the same [__]
they're always they can't choose a Lane
right they're like hey you should be a
parent you should be a parent we're
gonna force you to give birth to a child
whether you raise it yourself or give it
up for adoption we're not going to give
you any support by the way but when you
give it up for adoption that person who
adoption is not a biological parent and
therefore they're not a parent pick a
[__] Lane I mean the idea that
they're like oh we have so many babies
out there that need to be saved we
should adopt them right like all right
word I adopted one and you're like oh
but guess what biologically you didn't
have that baby so you don't really care
are you really apparent are you really
are you really
um actually
um you're not a parent it's just like I
mean like Jesus Christ
if we are really to compare any any
person
to Christian values right
you know the idea that like you know
when you're sick I took care of you when
you didn't have shelter I brought you in
when you were hungry I fed you when
you're thirsty you know all the stuff
and so you look at foster parents or uh
uh
adopt you know the idea
that they are that loving and that
caring and and actually embody whether
or not they are Christians right or or
religious or you know God uh following
or whatever
the idea that these people actually
embody those Christian values in empathy
to care for another person like Jesus
would is so telling that you have you
have a bucket of vomit like Marjorie
Taylor green who's willing to open up
her pale mouth like her [__]
like a [__] Muppet character uh on
some on some show right the idea that
Marjorie Taylor green wants to attack
and be like oh well biologically you're
not actually a mother go [__] yourself
okay let's not talk about Christian
values considering the fact that you
have cheated on your husband on multiple
multiple religions at Affairs divorced
doesn't sound like a biological marriage
to me yeah does it sound like you live
in a god-loving uh parental unit type of
relationship right the idea that this
woman has the [__] audacity the gall
the balls because we know Large Marge
has them the idea that she would even
say something like that to another
person who said you know what
I can't have kids my own or I feel like
there are so many kids out there that I
should do my part and and adopt kids
like why would you attack someone like
that why would you ever I mean I know
why because she's a [__] bigot right
a terrible human it's all it's all
theater though right this is theater
she's trying what she's trying to do is
what happened last week uh she's trying
to attack she's trying to get silent so
she can say see I'm the victim I'm being
oppressed I'm having my speech canceled
and committee hearings a political T
again makes a great Point here she's a
bucket of [__] vomit that's what she
is she's a bucket of [__] bombing and
she's the one that's running around
concerned about children in schools that
was the whole point of her little
[__] tirade about how adoptive
parents aren't parents she was like oh
you're the one who destroyed children's
education no it was the coronavirus you
[__] idiot right it was a coronavirus
that prevented us from Gathering up
children so we didn't kill people
unintentionally with a buyer that was
spreading like wildfires killing people
you [__] idiot that's what happened
we had to deal with it and they were
trying to set policy in the moment
rather they knew stuff or didn't know
stuff they don't know the future they
can't tell the future they were trying
to set policy that would help
you mean save the children right that
thing that they always say but you know
what it's the same [__] it's
the same [__] that are trying
to silence people and state legislators
when they're asking for gun reform so
[__] children aren't gunned down or
just stay the hell out of parental
consent altogether and here's a great um
clip of AOC speaking about this with
Justin Jones from Tennessee
representative Justin Jones uh at her
side Washington but she's speaking about
fascism more than anything because
that's what this is all about that's
what Marjorie Taylor Green's talking
about that's what they're [__] trying
to push that's just nonsense of you're
not what I want you to be therefore
you're not anything at all and you don't
get to be you don't even get to exist
right and if she was really concerned
about children and education she would
be concerned about [__] weapons of
war throwing high-powered High Velocity
pieces of ammunition all around schools
through the bodies tearing through the
bodies of children but she's not but
let's watch this clip of AOC telling her
what what fascism is and how it's a
threat for these
these [__] duly elected official in
this case the president United States
will take office legislatures across the
country looked at that and say you know
what let's try to get representative
Jones out from Office let's try it again
representative Zoe Zephyr in Montana out
of office try to kick out the people
because we cannot beat them but I cannot
emphasize enough they will not win this
is the last gasp of a movement that is
dying this is what fascism does when it
is on its hind heels it is always
darkest before Dawn we are winning this
thing that's right now there's more to
this clip and it goes on and she says it
about four different ways but she's
right fascism is back it is backed in
the corner we've got them in a corner
and they are fighting for their little
fashion lives okay and they know it they
know they know that the majority is not
on their side why do you think cleta
Mitchell over the weekend was caught in
audio saying we don't want college
students voting [__] that [__] if
they're voting we're [__] we can't our
ideas suck folks our ideas suck and when
you have sucky ideas you need to make
sure people aren't voting because if
they're voting they're gonna vote
against shitty ideas right and that's
what that's what AOC is trying to say
here which totally goes into the idea
that the Republican party is afraid of
the youth which are active engaged and
outspoken right and they are afraid and
that is why there's that you know that
Minority of people but it's a fascist
minority of people who are saying oh
well we should raise the voting age to
21. not 18. we should do it to 21. you
know because they want to eliminate a
majority of those college students
because when you're in college you know
21 22 is when you're in your senior year
as you're going out so they're hoping
that they can silence a majority three
quarters will say and if they do that
then they'll be able to completely win
and say oh well we don't want to offer
voting at colleges because we don't want
those kids being active right no what
they don't want is they don't want
Democratic left-leaning people being
activated and engaged on campuses they
want them to be silenced but you know
they're they're willing to uh to
sacrifice their own right-leaning
students right their the right-leaning
youth because they know that they're
also in the minority if you compare the
two it's [__] out wait it's a [__]
David versus Goliath it's the same it's
the same just the same it'll show up
almost the same percentage as the rest
of the country on almost any issue like
I don't want to go broke because of a
medical bill you're gonna have the
majority a high majority that's like
yeah we don't want to go broke because
of medical bills you're going to have a
high majority of people like yeah we
need to have common sense gun safety
around weapons of war like these are
high majorities and it's going to
reflect the same in gen Z like that's
going to be the same as gen Z are you
for democracy are you against it it's
going to be the same type of high ass
majority right and really probably even
higher than the normal population Amanda
makes a good point here let Republicans
eat rake [__] them that's perfect now I
I do want to add a point before we move
on here yeah about rakes and I've told
the audience this but I want to
reiterate it we may we may have some
preliminary designs of let them eat rake
um possibly some merch coming
so stay tuned stay tuned you might you
might get some uh rake merch soon coming
soon uh also Mighty librarian brings up
a good point I love the quote for
inspiration It's always darkest before
Dawn and that's um she goes on AOC if
you want to watch the clip you can go to
the Twitter page and you can see the
clip or Tennessee holler headset out
there um that's you publish this part
but the clip that I should but it is a
great quote darkest before Dawn because
they are on their heels I'm telling you
I'm very optimistic about our democracy
I'm very optimistic about the pro
democracy Coalition in this country but
we have to keep going we can't fall
asleep yeah right we got we got it we
gotta yeah
the the you got you gotta you gotta stay
up you gotta pull an all-nighter it's
the thing that you got to do I do want
to point out something so Kelly Voice
direct said and didn't your husband
expose himself to minors I believe this
is this is in relation to Marjorie
Taylor Green Oh you only have one
question or one correction though it's
not actually marger Taylor that would be
another yes representative that would be
representative Lauren bobert out of
Rifle Colorado and his name is Jason
right
Jason Jason
he exposed himself to Lauren bobert when
she was 17 as well as two other people
in a bowling alley of all places because
that's how you know when you're gonna
find find your true love the man that
you have children with the man that you
have kids with and one of those kids
then allegedly got a 15 year old girl
pregnant and they're very proud to be a
36 year old grandma
well they they are very proud of young
and dumb that's what they want and
that's what the Republican Party want
people to be they want their their their
demographic young and dumb they don't
want to educate them they don't want to
prepare them they don't they do not want
them to be ready for what the world is
going to bring at them they'd rather
have them uh you know close-minded
short-sighted and [__] idiots right
and and that is the unfortunate truth
that the Republican party wants they
want to control their demographic their
voting block to be uh yes I accept
everything you tell me and I will do the
thing that you tell me to do and they
will vote exactly down the down the belt
they'll vote red even though it's
against their own best interests it
takes away their health care against
those sheep I'm voting exactly the Sheep
right the Sheepish as I as I bomb my way
down the [__] ballot I am going to
accept everything thing you tell me is
truth I'm going to say that they're
corrupt not you guys I'm going to say
that they're evil not you guys I'm gonna
say you know they're gonna say that
we're smart and we know what's best for
you no at the end of the day these
people Republicans are working against
you they're not in your own best
interest they are selfish they are
corrupt they are evil just look at
Marjorie Taylor green just look at
Tennessee Republicans just look at
Montana Montana Republicans you look at
anything Republicans we're aggressive
we're aggressive regressive regressive
absolutely destructive that's their MO
that's their MO I want to give you an
update here on Twitch Gabe Sanchez yeah
we're gonna get to a thousand no oh hell
yeah 900 948
[Music]
yes 9 48 and and we've got we've gotten
I almost 20. there's one let's see one
then two three four five there's like I
don't know almost 20 new Amazon Prime
subscribers and there's 948 followers
damn Paul Young makes a good point here
and because the darkest before Dawn is a
good quote but this one's good too when
they go low plow the [__] over them I'm
like yeah [__] it this whole when they
go low we go high [__] no no I mean
technically technically when they go low
I am higher to plot over them right
right
that's not a bad point that's not right
like it's true
I'm in a high look also strategically
for those people who are like man I'm a
military man I got my wish I got my gun
holy [__] you need to know when you're
like hey where am I an advantage right
it's not low the advantage is high you
want the high vantage point right right
that is the position for all those
[__] military militias got my gun pew
pew man [__] high high high high do
that do that redneck voice again do it
uh all right uh what did I say I forgot
what I said just say just tell me that
you like your cousin you know what I'm
saying hey man
whatever man
that that's all horrible oh that's
horrible are you are you trying to mimic
me no no if anything if anything I don't
know I don't know what character life is
like it's like oh I'll talk like country
so I'll talk yeah I can talk about
countries
hey man I'm not mocking you man I'm just
telling you right now I'm having a good
time on this podcast I'm having I'm a
delightful time calling these [__]
bigots these goddamn Republican biggest
that's better that's much better that's
much better and I love to go pew pew man
but you know what I like to go I like to
go pew pew with the license proper
training you know making sure that
there's a mental health assessment and
I'll go QP all the time man awesome
a mental health what assessment that's a
big word yeah you know you know I mean
you know what you got ass and assessment
that makes me chuckle every time you
know not as crazy and weird as [__]
Tucker God damn speaking of Tucker
speaking attack or should we go to that
yeah
man now that your mic is working yeah
okay so um
the video that Tucker put out it's
mainly word salad it really is with the
sign of Lies the way the way that I
interpret it and it's mainly we can play
the video and I'll tell you what I feel
what I believe the video is
yo you you mean you mean like why he
said what he said at this point because
yeah I think there's a few reasons why
he said what he said but at the end of
the video he makes like this
sign off right and the sign off reminds
me of something but I want people to
listen to it and then I will tell you
what I think after so this is like two
minutes long I'm gonna stop it a couple
times because I wanna I wanna say a few
things during it yeah yeah that's fine
but here I know here's here's here's
Tucker here we go
good evening it's Tucker Carlson one of
the first things you realize when you
step outside the noise for a few days is
how many genuinely nice people there are
in this country kind and decent people
people who really care about what's true
and a bunch of hilarious people also why
does he why does he think that hilarious
people aren't kind and decent people
yeah well I'm hilarious why is hilarious
why
oh my God what happened did Tony close
himself out now it's just that gave sand
says it is the Gabe Sanchez podcast
welcome welcome welcome [__] Tony
Michaels we're not letting him back at
God damn it we're back all right I have
no idea what happened wow for a moment
it was all me baby I didn't have any I
didn't have any control I didn't have a
video I didn't do anything I didn't
touch [__] that was on your end you
closed yourself out and I don't know
what the hell happened I have no idea I
don't know all right let's keep going I
don't know why he thinks hilarious is a
Bad Thing hilarious is kind of a good
thing but you know whatever here we go
funny people who aren't cruel okay
that's important right funny people who
aren't cool well also cruel people
uh try to use a different type of humor
right they punch down they attack that's
not humor that's uh that's just that's
just being a [__] [__] right but
funny people right hilarious people
comical people there's an empathy that
comes with that and understanding right
whether it's self-deprecating humor
right or it's understanding hey there's
a group of people that we need to punch
up against but understanding with a
common group of people who are listening
to say hey I relate to you and you
relate to me uh but the things that
Tucker does on his show or the things
that people who support Tucker do is
hateful it's not it's not comedy they
might want to be like oh it's so funny
man it's it's not comedy wow Paul says
Tony's hungover I I think is that true
well is it true Tony it is true is it
true okay so yeah I am hungover but I I
think Paul I think you meant Tony's
hilarious but it is true I am hilarious
exclusive you can beat both things well
let's let's hear more nonsense from the
king of nonsense here Tucker Carlson a
lot of those it's got to be the majority
of the population even now
so that's heartening the other thing you
notice when you take a little time off
is how unbelievably stupid most of the
debates you see on television are
how many debates are on TV
what does that mean is there like is
there a debate channel that I'm missing
somewhere I mean maybe C-SPAN
what do they I mean they might hold the
baits but mostly I mean they have the
base between both sides but I mean like
we're also this is a dude who wants to
[__] the green m m and then did a whole
hour-long segment about dude tanning
their testicles right okay so the idea
that Tucker cross is like man a lot of
people have stupid real stupid debates
really you you have these people on your
show to talk about the dumbest [__]
[__] I've ever heard right you attack
Hunter Biden even though you're you were
buddy buddy with him for a while you
even asked to get a lot of
recommendation for your son Buckley
right you bring on the tick tock lady
who's okay wait a second wait a second
we'll stop right there
I gotta address something right now
because Tucker Carlson has done a lot of
a lot of horrible [__] to this country
horrible [__] yeah I cannot believe
that I did not point out and have in my
brain one of the most horrible things
that he's done name his Saint son
Buckley yeah what the [__] Buckley car
like if there was if there is are you
kidding me
I don't go after Buck but I go after so
I have a what was that that Buckley's an
adult now though right yeah yeah yeah
yeah so [__] Buckeyes Buckley Buckley is
a [__] nepo baby okay if people don't
know what nepo baby it's a nepotism baby
right uh he completely benefited from
Tucker Carlson's connections also Hunter
Biden's connections apparently yeah and
Hunter I mean like he you know uh
Buckley Carlson works for Jim Banks
right and so there's Jim Banks who's Jim
Banks that sounds familiar it sounds
like a congressman somewhere it sounds
like a guy who was trying to say that
Jan six wasn't Jan six I'm trying to say
Nancy
didn't call in the National Guard that's
weird man it's weird and then you find
oh there's video of her doing that exact
thing exactly he named his son Buckley
you [__] evil piece of [__] okay
let's let's continue with the word salad
because it the word salad gets worse it
gets worse but listen
they're completely irrelevant they mean
nothing in five years we won't even
remember that we had them trust me as
someone who's participated
so so he's like debates are horrible
they suck but also I'm a part of it
right also I that's what I do is I do
shitty debate like what the [__] what in
the hell you want to know a shitty
debate that he had actually so when Jon
Stewart came on it was 2004 2003 I think
uh when Jon Stewart came on the CNN
Crossfire show right and he's that was a
debate show yeah yeah that was a debate
show and he [__] handed Tucker
Carlson embarrassed him on his own show
and then when the new CNN president came
in was like yeah and literally cited one
of the reasons as to why the show that
was because of that was because of that
appearance which is like I think total
14 minutes of his like appearance on the
show right but you could really distill
it down to like a minute and right uh is
it all is another thing I have included
in the in the what was that that's on
tiger Carlson that it's going to be
coming out today and in that clip he
[__] is like dude stop you guys are
political hacks you are only hell
helping their strategy by legitimizing
what they're saying you're putting them
on a [__] Network CNN and letting
them just [__] go you're not
challenging them you're not calling out
you're not doing anything that would
make you seem as like a legitimate
journalist and and that's something he
was like you got you you should go to
journalism school like you would you're
[__] 35 and you wear a bow tie right
that that's probably I would say if you
had to ask the CNN executive who fired
Tucker at the time yeah and like okay
give me give me 10 seconds of clip of
why you fired them is when is when Jon
Stewart hands him his ass over the bow
tie because Tucker Carlson's face
on camera when Jon Stewart is doing the
bow tie jokes oh my God he looks like
such a [__] little [__] and it is
hilarious and the other the other 10
seconds would be when Tucker Carlson's
like well you have a show and you're not
doing journalism and Jon Stewart's like
I follow a show that's a bunch of
Puppets making prank calls man I'm on
Comedy Central dude part of our show is
satire and parody you [__] and
I'm I'm presenting the news in a way
that's more digestible than what you are
doing right and as a journalist and that
was the point that Jon Stewart's trying
to make is like hey you have a
responsibility to present the news in a
digestible way that the American people
can understand and you're not you're
just you're just piling [__] up
everywhere yeah and this idea that
Tucker Carlson was part of the debate
and now that he's fired and no longer
part of the debate for three days the
debate now it's [__] it's it's all gone
to [__] in three days come on man give
me a break no one cares about you that
[__] much Tucker they really don't
let's keep listening though how he
thinks he's relevant and yet at the same
time and this is the amazing thing the
undeniably big topics the ones that will
Define our future oh what are those
virtually no discussion at all civil
liberties emerging science
corporate power no [__] oh my God no
one's covering those at all no one's
actually you can give me a [__] break
come on Tucker no one three days man
you've been off the air three [__]
days and all of a sudden everything goes
to get the [__] out he's trying to he's
trying to you know he's trying to paint
the picture that is
I'm Tucker Carlson and I'm
anti-establishment [__] that dude Tommy
Carlson is the establishment he worked
for for a year we're talking well I mean
when he joining look at him look at him
I know I know but let's you know for
anyone who ever questioned this whole
anti-establishment or supported the idea
that Tucker is anti-establishment
that's not to say that you couldn't be a
wealthy white dude on a show that is
anti-establishment but to say that you
are like I'm anti-establishment and
these corporate guys won't let me talk
about the things I want to talk about
right if you go through the literal
footage you'll find that in Mobile
location multiple times Tucker Carlson
has has [__] propped up the Murdoch
family to be like they they let us say
whatever we want to say First Amendment
they believe in it they never question
they never doubt us they never tell us
what we can and can't say on this
program and I thank them and God bless
them right Tucker Carlson comes from
money okay his dad was [__] CIA his
mom his stepmom was [__] the the
[__] Swanson TV dinner heiress right
like you have the you have money power
control wealth all these things that he
comes from right he's establishment he's
as establishment as they [__] come
right and then he gets a talk show right
he's on three different networks okay
fire from all of them it need the first
person to be fired from all three yeah
MSNBC CNN and now Fox News
that's hilarious Tucker go for three
that is amazing record [__] put it in
the Guinness bro world record book right
now because no one's gonna beat that but
the idea that Tucker Carlson and anyone
who wants to be like oh look he's back
he's talking against about the
establishment right he's talking about
Rupert Murdoch and Fox News and calling
out these corporate people are trying to
control the narrative Tucker is trying
to control the narrative by saying that
he's the victim right he's not the
victim he did this to himself he did
this to himself and I'm not saying Fox
News or Rupert Murdoch are [__]
saviors here whoa whoa tree Anne on
YouTube says and PBS so it's four
he got fired at PBS is that is that
right I don't we need to check that
because if it is for holy [__]
that that's that's significant that's
significant I'm just gonna say while
you're checking out let's keep see what
else Tucker has to say I do want to I do
want to update everyone on the twitch on
the progress that we have on Twitch 957
and Counting okay okay okay okay here we
go I got the update here all right so
from 2000 to 2005 he was on CNN and had
yeah hosted the spin room and then 2001
he was on CrossFire and that was
canceled in 2005. but from 2004 2005 his
show Tucker Carlson unfiltered lasted
about a year and ran at the same time as
CNN's Crossfire it was a part of an
effort by the public media network uh to
add ideological balance
on PBS on PBS it says but it ran for a
year but was he fired or did he just run
his contract right I gotta look that up
there is a difference between not
renewing a contract and actually firing
you because CNN MSNBC and now you're
fired from PBS I think that probably is
contract ran out we just ran out right
so we probably had a contract that ran
and that's different I'll give Tucker
that that's different than being [__]
ganned okay yeah but but it is it is
also he was on PBS apparently but let's
see what else Tucker had to say here in
his little statement was last time you
heard a legitimate debate about any of
those issues
debates like that are not permitted in
American Media oh my God political
parties and their donors have reached
consensus on what benefits them it
really feels like he was on the internet
over the last few days and he kept
seeing that clip of Jon Stewart yeah
owning his ass on his show Crossfire the
whole debate thing there's a there's a
there's an interview he did years later
where uh Tucker art yeah no Tucker and
he's doing an interview with this
reporter and it's a sit-down kind of
segment and that's brought up and in
this thing they talk about like oh he
came on the show and you know he won
that debate kind of thing right and he's
like that's weird I I felt like I uh I
didn't lose that debate I felt like I
won that debate but according to people
on the internet they think that I lost
which is kind of weird like look I've
debated and I've lost I've lost debates
and I've admitted to it before bull
[__] [__] you've never you've never
admitted to losing a debate that you've
lost and I'm sure you've lost a ton but
that is you know that's the revisionist
storytelling right there so Tucker in
this interview basically says uh I
didn't lose the debate people online and
people elsewhere have commented on it
years after the fact and said that I
lost but I don't think I lost I mean
I've known when I've lost a base and
I've admitted when I've lost debates but
I I don't think I lost that debate I I
think I won that debate and that's what
he said
come on Tucker years later on years
later it wasn't really debate it was Jon
Stewart on their show it wasn't the
debate but you know whatever debate has
rules debate has moderators I mean
there's a certain structure to debate
that was a TV show is entertainment
that's what the whole point of what Jon
Stewart was trying to tell them is that
this is all [__] you're not actually
having debate on this show you're you're
presenting it as debate when it's not
you're [__] lying to your audience is
what Jon Stewart was trying to say well
let's see how much more he talks about
debate in this video he's supposed to be
giving us here I don't know it's weird
and they actively collude to shut down
any conversation about it collude
suddenly the United States looks very
much like a one-party State
what are you what the [__] so now now
he's doing the whole both sides same
[__] yeah hey hey
um anyone out there who loves tyt anyone
out there who loves dyt and is so tired
of Me Knocking on them because they both
sides everything hey Tucker's on the
same page as them what does that tell
you huh what does that tell you what
does that tell you I said the other day
that rumor has it people are saying that
Tucker might go to dyt I don't know wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait Olga says
tyt Carlson
ah
that's pretty good that's pretty good
t-y-t-y-t Carlson Unleashed that's it
unleash Unleashed untriggered because
donor is triggered right so Tucker would
have to be on un triggered Okay let's
listen to him untriggered here
that's a depressing realization but it's
not permanent oh our current orthodoxies
won't last oh they're brain dead nobody
actually believes that what hardly
anyone's life is improved by them I'm
I'm I'm fine this is we're a minute 32
into this two minute clip and I'm
finding it hard to follow at this point
I don't know if it's I don't know if
it's the the wooden background that he
has here when he's in his steam room or
something I don't know where the [__]
this is at it's kind of weird this is
this is the place that he has those
interviews where the like Tucker Carlson
original oh okay
this is his set at his house yeah yeah
but he's filming this [__] from his
phone oh okay and well and that may be
why it seems [__] weird but it just
oh man Tucker it I I don't know what
you're talking about now like I I was
kind of on board but now you're just now
you're just saying words that you want
to say he was like his words
it was like he had a list he's like I
want to say all these words let's put
them in a script and he ran out of
script after a minute so then he's just
put he's just saying the words well yeah
I mean he knows what he needs to say to
activate right his his will not woke but
code word a code word activation of the
manga sheep right so it's
[Laughter]
the Winter Soldier like you say certain
words yeah yeah you're like 17 you know
Trump 24 Trump 2024. there's like
[__] zombies or something yeah
activated by certain languages at the
very end I'll tell you why I think what
I think about this video okay well let's
let's continue with the word salad here
let's see if he comes up how many words
he comes up with that he wants to say
this moment is too inherently ridiculous
to continue and so it won't okay the
people in charge know this that's why
they're hysterical and aggressive see
they're worried I've given up persuasion
they're resorting to force
but it won't work when honest people say
what's true calmly and without
embarrassment they become powerful oh
[__] oh here it is here's the objection
part of it here's the projection he's
like oh I told the truth so I'm so
powerful that the establishment had to
get rid of me because I started telling
the truth get the [__] out of here with
that nonsense I'm telling you he's gonna
he plays his [__] and what is
beautiful about this is I literally
wrote my whole segment before he made
this video last night and you called it
you called it well there's a part in
there where I'm like he's not the victim
he did this to himself right he said
this crazy [__] and it caught up with
him well and I said this okay I said
this time and time again I believe why
uh Rupert Murdoch
in particular one in Tucker Carlson gone
is because Rupert Murdoch wanted
creative control back of that 8 PM slot
because in Tucker's contract he had
creative control that's why everyone's
like how does he just get away with
saying whatever the [__] he wants and
I'm telling you that 800 million bucks
and some of the lawsuits that are going
to come down on Fox News and Tech or
Carlson from some of these employees
that's happening it's because they they
didn't snatch that creative control from
him and that's why Rupert Murdock is
doing that for that creative control
over the 8 PM hour he didn't give a [__]
who is Tucker Bill Riley he didn't give
a [__] that 8 PM hour is worth a lot of
[__] money and they want the creative
control back but let's let's see what
old tucum's has here
at the same time the Liars who've been
trying to silence shrink they become
weaker really that's the iron law of the
universe wait true things Prevail really
where can you still find Americans
saying true things there aren't many
places left but there are some and
that's enough
as long as you can hear the words there
is hope
see you soon
all right this is what I think of this
video this very last line where he's
like you know if you listen up There's
Hope blah blah it's a [__] cue drop
you think that's what it is I don't I
don't honestly think that's what he's
doing but it it plays to the same nature
if you break down a cue drop or any cue
drop that has been done she just painted
with such a broad brush it's such a
broad brush and it's done in such a way
where you're like okay my Patriots be
alert and ready to hear the activation
words that you need to be told that will
get you to you know whatever just stand
back and stand by you remember that so
so when you hear where he's like you
just need to like if you play that last
play that lasts like 15 seconds again
deep
this [__] guy I want to break down
what the video looks like too we might
have time yeah let's listen to this
shrink and they become weaker that's the
iron law of the universe true things
prevail
where can you still find Americans
saying true things there aren't many
places left but there are some and
that's enough
as long as you can hear the words there
is hope
see you soon so this idea that first off
you know yeah see you soon
oh boy oh man oh that's so true
look at look at my my nice set the fox
newspaper that now I'm using my cell
phone to record from oh man how cute how
are you cute manners out there now I see
what you're saying about the case thing
it sounds like it sounds very similar to
a cue drop that has been done previously
we're like okay I'm not going to tell
you exactly what to look out for but
keep those ears perked and ready because
there's something that's gonna happen
and a little pension
[Laughter]
yes that that is my yes that's uh that's
a what would you call that Roberts are
called that boroughs I don't know
oh
Tucker Carlson I think from now on
we're an impersonation of Tucker Carlson
why why can't we have a fully speech why
won't you listen to what I say you know
what that reminds me I'll tell the truth
what it reminds me a [__] Lord of the
Rings it's like in that it's in that
same vein of like the the gollum it's
like precious my precious
precious that's that's the kind of voice
that I feel like somebody said that I
should do somebody said Elmo
but I don't that's not elbow I feel like
it's kind of like Gollum almost like um
is that quite Golem but there's got to
be some more garbliness this is elbow
this is Elmo that's you know you kind of
you know who you kind of remind me yeah
in that moment the way that you said
that was uh Ken Jeong
Ken Jeong
the comedian he uh does he do the voice
that voice he has a similar voice when
he plays the character in The Hangover
oh okay you know where he's like oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
nothing not the it's not the same like
raspiness but it's the same like
yeah yeah anyway what is that
character's name from Hangover damn it
I've watched like all three of them
Leslie yes Leslie uh God damn it
Leslie something
[Music]
ciao yeah [__] [__]
[__] I mean yeah that's should
I change it from Surf's Up [__]
to Taylor [__] I don't know
maybe I'll may all do that but from now
on when I do Tucker I'll try the blue
books I don't know some people think um
some people think that I should do voice
over but you know I don't know uh now
okay Gabe Sanchez let's let's look down
to some serious business here about
Tucker's set okay you said he's using a
cell phone right everyone he's using a
cell phone and this is because I would
unless he here unless the cameras
because he's got you know like a three
camera set that uh or two to three
cameras that he normally he's gotta have
cameras in this set though right no I
know I know but also if you have this
set that's Fox property so I wouldn't be
surprised if Fox was like okay we're
coming with the [__] U-Haul and we're
picking that [__] up you know like I I
unless or or he doesn't want to look
like he's using their equipment right
right all right I mean he doesn't have
anyone he doesn't have any when they are
to man the equipment because his team
either was well yeah
or you think that's the other reason why
the writing sucks
well you know what's funny in that same
interview where where Tucker was trying
to say how he didn't lose the debate
with Jon Stewart he talks about how he's
like well
I don't know if I want to be doing this
like commentating all the time on TV
like I don't know if that's really a
thing I want to do I think of myself as
a writer like I was originally a writer
because we have to remember like he he
worked for the Heritage Foundation and
was all about writing that [__]
problem on The Daily what do you want an
editor at the Daily Caller too well yeah
that Daily Caller is isn't that his
company I I don't know I believe that
that's what I'm asking I guess but yeah
he worked at the Heritage Foundation
which he just gave us the 50th
Anniversary that he gave his speech on
Friday and a lot of people like oh
that's why you know that's why Murdoch
responded the way he did uh I don't
think so but
um
you have to remember that he has a he
has a history of of writing but the way
he's like oh yeah like I'm a writer
first and foremost that's what I think
of myself if that's the case then holy
[__] man this is some awful writing it's
a bunch it's like it's it was mad lib
style like here it is here's a buzzword
here's a buzzword I'll string it
together and I know it had no Direction
it really didn't I mean like where he
started and where he ended it it didn't
make any [__] sense he was just
saying a bunch of [__] and trying to
get some shots in on people right it's
really weird if he wanted to do that he
should have just got shots in on people
and not tried to [__] but I don't
think he can legally I don't think it is
well I don't know if it's necessarily
and then I compete but there probably is
a an NDA that he has to abide by right
now well but that's part of that
non-compete though I mean it would be
part I mean I mean yeah I mean yes I
mean they're separate documents
obviously but in in that NDA when you
leave right when you sign a contract the
uh typically what happens when you sign
the contract you're like great I have
this non-compete clause in there
typically I don't I don't remember if
there's a non like you you disparage
your company when you sign your out like
when you sign your your papers when you
like yep I agree I'm leaving in there
typically you have language around what
the what the language is to say like you
cannot talk poorly about your previous
employer and also remember that you
agree that you you know you'll wait a
year or 18 months or two years or
whatever to not go to another place to
or a competitor whatever but I think
what's happening right now is he's
trying to say in the most vague way as a
slight to the murdochs and Fox News to
talk about Corporate America the
corporate interest they're the ones who
are going to tell you what you can and
can't say even though just two years ago
Tucker Carlson literally said I want to
thank the Murdoch family because they do
not question what I say they believe as
a a purveyor of the the the First
Amendment as as truth Seekers they do
not tell us what we can and cannot say
they let us do what we want and we
support them and they support us and we
love them God bless them literally 2021
well and that's what I'm saying that's
what I'm saying though that Rupert
Murdoch wants to be able to tell his
host you can't say that right on my
network I mean it cost him it just cost
him 800 million bucks and so they want
yeah and that's why because everyone was
wondering why him first right like well
because he's the one that has creative
control and he has he has Tucker Had
Creative control to say whatever the
[__] he wanted on Fox news right in the
highest viewed hour and they're on their
entire 24-hour platform right and it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter if it's
Tucker Carlson or anyone else it's going
to be the highest viewed hour that's
just how it's going to be because that's
the prime time hour that's why it's
called Prime Time
prime time right
Deliverance tonight we're Tucker Carlson
Primetime [__] and that's also a reason
why he he released that video he
released that video at 8pm well around
8pm right well I mean I mean that's
that's nobody's watching supposedly he's
gonna try to compete for that time slot
is what yeah is that what you're saying
because that's what I whatever he does
wherever he goes well people know he's
gonna try to come at that time right
he's gonna try to compete for that time
slot so he could say oh I got more
viewers than Fox but it's not going to
happen that's why that's why Tucker is
completely [__] here and anyone who's
defending him or thinking he's going to
be back and bigger than ever you are a
dumb [__] you are such a dumb
son of a [__] you do not understand how
[__] humans work if you just you're
not getting it the reason why the reason
why Rupert Murdoch wanted his creative
control back is so he can control what
it said in the 8 PM hour because it's so
important that they don't spend another
800 million dollars because of this
[__] idiot and a lot of people are
like oh well it's not really Tucker's
fault there was other Bad actors there
was more Bad actors in Tucker I'm like
yeah but those actors don't have
creative control Rupert and the board
can go to them and say shut the [__] up
you don't get to say that [__] no more
and they did they stopped Hannity does
not have creative control he does not
like Tucker did in his contract he just
doesn't and that's why I don't think
Hannity is going to go to APM who do you
think is going to take his spot who do
you think if you had to get I don't know
they they said they're going to have a
rotating cast of people right so they're
going to try and essentially they're
gonna try it's like tryouts is that what
you're trying to say yeah they're gonna
have tryouts and see kind of who who
comes in I guess reportedly like 500 600
000 Subs viewers dropped
um from the previous days when he was on
at 8pm to now I mean I know that people
don't like Brian Kilmeade they are not
like he [__] sucks yeah yeah I mean
they're all boring I mean I'll give it
I'll give I'll give Tucker this Tucker
is an interesting character right he's
he's like that [__] Uncle it's like
well it's like a car wreck he can't look
away right yeah I know exactly I mean
like it is it is like a yeah like a
co-workers like I see it happening in
slow motion and yet I know it's gonna
happen but I can't look away right it's
like I mean you have to give him Credit
in the sense of like if you looked
across all social channels millions
millions of views millions of plays
millions of people who are commenting on
his thing that he did that night or the
previous night or whatever right and I'm
definitely guilty of it I [__] play
those clips you play those clips we make
fun of those clips right obviously our
whoever replaces him in the 8 PM slot
we're gonna be playing those clips baby
we're gonna because they're because
they're gonna say the dumbest [__] in
those spots and the most people are
going to be paying attention at that
point that's why they're gonna say the
dumbest [__] that's why they're gonna
say it I you know what I God damn it I
really wanted to spend a little more
time on the um don't worry I have a
feeling he's gonna be on bonehead of the
week yeah it feels like that yeah
it could be because you got [__] [__]
canned what a loser what a [__] loser
loser what a [__] loser that's a
loser girl Tucker Carlson is a [__]
loser [__] it Butch
um okay so I'm gonna give an update on
on Twitch we're getting so close and I I
Believe by the end of the day uh we'll
have a thousand followers on Twitch we
got 961 you guys are [__] awesome you
guys are [__] awesome not only that
we've we've gotten like 20 new Prime
subscribers over on Twitch and if you're
not aware here's what happens if you
have a Amazon Prime account you can link
it to your Twitch account you get one
free subscription it doesn't cost you a
single thing if you're a Prime member to
give us that subscription on Twitch and
we get a couple bucks literally it's
like two or three dollars and but it
helps out in Mass so when the more there
is the more there is for support of the
show and it doesn't cost you a thing
which is really cool that's the kind of
support I like we get a little bit of
money and it doesn't cost you a single
nickel
um so go link your Prime account and
thank you to everyone today
who resubscribed as well you have to
re-subscribe every single month and it
takes like three seconds to go in and
resubscribe so if you haven't done that
please do that thank you to everyone who
re-subscribed And subscribe with their
Prime account but also the people who
followed today uh and I think we just
got another one I think I think so I
think so let's see and then yep 962 so
thank you very much for following I know
we're gonna get to a thousand by the end
of the day we'll have a thousand so
tomorrow I'll give you an update on the
show tomorrow's Friday
you know what that means Gabe Sanchez
today we put out the poll for the
bonetta week as long as the responsible
parties remind us
um
they know who they are reminding us
sending us message hey boneheads you
need to post a poll for bonehead of the
week so make sure make sure you follow
us here on YouTube as well not just
twitch because this is where you vote
for bonehead of the week on YouTube on
the community tab you can also vote on
Twitter so go follow us at Tony Michaels
pod on Twitter you'll be able to vote
for bone net of the week on YouTube
or on Twitter also you know what while
you're out there supporting the show and
it doesn't cost you a single nickel Go
download every single episode Gabe
Sanchez on Apple Spotify Google it's
free99 over there you also get a five
finger discount on the um
on on the show at on your Facebook page
if you still have a Facebook account
follow us at the Tony Michaels you can
see the broadcast there it's five finger
discount on Facebook
but again I want to thank everyone who
linked their Prime account to their
Twitch account and gave us that one free
subscription today and all of you who
followed today to the Twitch account it
doesn't cost anything to follow and you
don't have to link your Prime account to
follow you just go over to Twitch on the
app or twitch.com and you just go to our
channel the Tony Michaels and hit the
follow button and Bam just like that
it's free it's free we like that kind of
support
free free free 99 free 99. it's so free
over here okay I'm glad you like the new
Decker Carlson voice I'll try to get the
Tucker Carlson voice going more often
thank you again to everyone who's
following us over on Twitch today don't
forget to subscribe on YouTube follow us
everywhere you can go to the Tony
michaels.com you can find that also
keep your keep your ears and eyes open
for any rake merch I think we're gonna
have it tomorrow yeah we're gonna have a
rake orange tomorrow also yeah oh no
what do you got what do you got oh I was
gonna say uh I got a
I have a new episode of what was that
coming out it's on Tucker Carlson
getting fired I make fun of him I mock
them I call them out check it out
um people who are on patreon that are
part of my community get ready I think
you'll like this one and for people who
aren't part of the community check out
the patreon I think you'll like what we
do right hang out we talk we chat every
Sunday we have a weekend Roundup or yeah
and just kind of you know talk about
what the [__] happened this week
what was that share.com
what was that so go to patreon.com I am
Gabe Sanchez or go to what was
thatshow.com to follow Gabe on patreon
see what he's doing over there while
you're on patreon don't forget to visit
my page the Tony Michaels I think I'll
put
um a draft of the whatever rake merch
may be coming wink wink uh I mean I put
a draft over there for people to give
some critique once we get a better we
had a rough rough draft this morning
yeah yeah from the artist and I think
we'll probably get a a better rough bird
draft from some of our things that we
wanted in
um as initial design points so maybe
I'll I'll send that over there today so
you guys can critique that as well sorry
for the audio problems
um but we got it fixed eventually sorry
I'm so so sorry
I mean it was totally worth it look I
can't see you out there they're getting
horny they're getting horny in the chat
I may not be able to
be able to oh Jesus Christ will you yeah
can you that you're making me horny now
can you stop
Jesus Christ
horny Thursdays horny Thursdays here on
the Johnny Michaels podcast
oh my God two hours a day
what what what in the hell do these
people I don't know why I don't know man
every single weekday Newton Eastern 11
Central 9 Pacific on YouTube Twitter and
twitch thanks to everyone who followed
us on Twitch today we're so close to a
thousand you're the best audience in the
goddamn world same time same place
tomorrow sir slap [__]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events in political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] them [__] em
[Music]
Murphy's mewborn headass Beacon